all right it is now 20 minutes past the
hour and it is time
to go for sql server hates you and i i'm
so happy that you've chosen this
specific session
in competition with some seriously heavy
hitters
and i'm equally happy that you're eager
to find out
just how evil sql server can be
so this story it started with a phone
call
and i was sitting in my office many
many years ago and the phone rang
so why i recognized the number to to be
a developer friend of mine
and i answered with the usual hello
and i was met with complete silence
you know the kind of silence that makes
you question if
the phone is actually working and just
as
i was about to say something again
my friend said sql server hates me
i thought about it for a second and then
realized that no
no sql server does not hate you
specifically it hates
everyone in equal measures
and that was kind of the inspiration to
create this session
because as with any profession it's it's
so easy to get stuck
within our own boxes so we're going to
cover among other things
some weird default settings in in sql
server
and some unintended consequences with
sql
and how isolation levels can and will
bite you in the posterior because
most of the time we think that a
developer doesn't
really need to think about how the
database does
stuff as long as it compiles right
one of the classic opinions from from
developers well it compiles it must run
it's it's good stuff
wrong knowing a bit more about how the
database actually works
and and how it it it
accepts and handles queries that
is what's going to bring you from a mere
programmer to
some kind of a developer dem i got ish
and in order to move skywards you need
to dig deeper you need to get a
better grasp of how the engine behaves
and you're gonna kind of appreciate why
some
techniques come with a pretty hefty
price tag
this hour is but a taste of all the
weird stuff out there
you need to know more you want to know
more
and you will know more in an hour
everything has
consequences especially with the
database
my name is alexander i am from
leadership in sweden
i have 23 years in it
pretty much all of it spent with data
databases
and infrastructure in some way shape or
form
i started working as a developer i
did a year and a half as a developer i
am no longer a developer
and i think the world is in agreement
that it is a good thing
that i am no longer a developer
yeah these days i worked for a theater
in sweden
and i have the best title ever principal
solutions architect
because nobody knows what i do but it's
easy to explain because i make data
matter because only data that
matters can can actually change anything
i do this by going all over the world i
used to do this by going all over the
world
to speak at conferences um teach courses
and
do consulting then the world ended so i
have been stuck
inside of my study for the last i don't
know eight or ten weeks
i know exactly what my study looks like
i am one of six data platform mvps in
sweden i co-host a podcast called need
even tech and yep
that is the dome logo for you that are
slightly older
but back to the database stuff
first of all let's talk about memory sql
server has the same relation to memory
as my cats do to food as in give me all
food now that has some consequences
i'm gonna give you a number anybody ever
seen this
well what if i tell you
that this is in megabytes yeah
so this is the default amount of memory
that sql server is allowed to consume
now i don't know about use or your
systems but
very few of my clients has this amount
of ram
so this is indeed a bit of an issue
because it turns out that there are
going to be
more than one thing on on a server these
days
i mean we most often talk about the sql
server but
we also have stuff like the sql server
analysis services or sql server
integration services or sql server
reporting services
or why don't we throw in some other
software on the server
as well all of this software requires
memory
and we haven't even talked about the
fact that the operating system
requires memory as well by the way do
you know what
a server with all the components of sql
server
in install this called yeah
it's called the clown car because it is
a bad
bad idea the only reason
why you would ever want to put
everything on the same box
is if you're strapped for cash when it
comes to licensing
otherwise it's it's it's a horrible idea
so it turns out that the different
editions of sql server
have different limitations unless you're
running the expensive edition or
as it's colloquially known the
enterprise edition
where you have no limitations at all
back where i come from most of my
clients unfortunately
run sql service standard edition and
that means that i have to
work with or i should say work around
the
limitations of that product the main one
is that sql server standard edition can
only handle
128 gigs of ram or
64 gigs of ram if you're unfortunate
enough to still be on
2012 or earlier
but let's look at what that really means
when you're talking memory in sql server
most often
people refer to the buffer cache the
buffer cache is where the actual data
blocks
end up when we query and manipulate data
right but there's more
there's a lot of other stuff going on
inside of sql server and
these are just a few of them so we have
the procedure cache we have the log
cache we have the system level data
structures
connection context god only knows what
again this is just
a small fraction of everything that's
going on inside of sql server
and here's the font surprisingly
little known fact still to this day
the addition limitation of 128 or 64
gigs
only applies to the buffer cache
it only applies to the barf cache let's
let's let that sink in for a second we
can thus have
more memory in a server and have sql
server actually use it
just not for the buffer cache so
let's put in 192
gigs inside of the server and set the
max server memory
to 166 gigs it's going to look like this
why would i want to do this well again
here's what what it's going to look like
we have 192 gigs
of memory on this box we need to leave
some of the memory to the operating
system
and whatever stuff we have on the box
that is not sql server per se
because especially if you've been at
this for a while and did some
some stuff with windows server 2003 and
you
inadvertently took away memory from the
operating system
it behaved pretty badly because the
server just fell over and died
now 20 going from 20 to
2003 to 2008 and 2012 and so on and so
forth
it's become better but windows does not
look kindly
on you taking away memory form from it
it does not like that so you need to
leave some
for the the operating system so back to
mac server memory
mac server memory is going to cover all
of these things
it's not just going to cover the buffer
cache so
in fact by putting in more memory in the
box
and setting max memory higher than the
addition memory limit it's the only way
to
really really really use your entire
memory allocation
i mean if you actually paid for your
your server why not use it to
to the max right so in short
do not put everything on the same box i
will find you if you do
understand the memory limits
work with them and always
always set a hard limit on memory
because otherwise
you will have a lot of processes that
want to eat up your memory and fight
between them
for for memory and you don't want to
find yourself in a situation where
secret server
has a lot of memory the operating system
wants that memory
and boots sql server out of the memory
space
it's going to be a while to get that
memory back
or get that data back into working
memory so
danger will rub us in danger
so my friend called me up again
and this time he explained that his
performance sucked
again but he'd been on the internet
and he had found the issue and he also
found the solution to the issue and he
just wanted to make sure that i knew
just how
easy it was to fix this weight
called cx packet thingy
oh dear let's unpack that a bit so what
is parallelism
well for starters parallelism is a
pretty difficult word if you're not
a native speaker
and what parallelism is it's it's the
the
the ability to cut something into small
bits and pieces you have seen
parallelism
in in query plans like this it says
parallelism distributes stream and over
there it says gather
stream and a lot of people
still to this day see this as an issue
but this is not an issue per se this is
the
this is kind of the shadow that a
potential issue
throws and up until 2019 sql server 2019
it is somewhat difficult to figure out
why and how stuff are going in in
parallel it's easier in 2019 and onwards
but
we're staying with primarily 2012 to
uh in this this session so
what if we took a huge query
i mean we we did a huge query in this
case a select
count from a product table either i can
just
throw this on one cpu
and burn that basically to the ground
and the other cpus are just going to go
me where you don't have anything to do
or i can add parallelism to this
now this is generally not something you
explicitly do
this is something that the engine is
going to
think about depending on the different
settings
so what's going to happen is we're going
to take this pretty big query and we're
going to chop it into small bits and
pieces
and that's that's pretty easy um
let's let's take an example say that i
have a bowl of skittles
you know the the multi-colored candies
and
i want to sort this into different piles
depending on the color so i can either
go blue blue
blue red red green over here and
yeah you're going to be bored within 15
seconds
or i can take this and make small
piles and give each and every one of you
your own pile that you can sort on your
own and when you're done
you bring me back the whole result so
the whole
bringing back our results that's what co
that's called the the gather streams
the issue is that at least
one of you is not going to care about my
skills at all because you're busy
watching uh cat videos on youtube or
looking at that
facebook or tech talk or whatever is the
new fad
i'm i'm getting old so i don't know what
tik tok is
and it doesn't matter what you're doing
you're just not sorting my skittles and
thus
you're holding up everybody else because
i cannot
count the number of different colored
skills until i have
everything back and that is exactly
what tends to happen with most not
always
but with most oltp workloads online
transaction processing workloads because
it is not
very good at pre paralyzing that is an
even harder word
so how is this an issue well
let me just say it's about to get worse
much worse
this is a computer
yes it is an old computer because this
is a dell optiplex pentium 2
266 megahertz
oh yeah megahertz not gigahertz
megahertz
old school stuff and this specific
machine um and this picture is taking
from a talk by connor cunningham uh
at sql bits a couple years back this
specific machine was the machine of gene
amdahl
and gene used to work for microsoft and
he wrote
a lot of the code for the optimizer cost
estimation algorithm
in in sql server so everything has a
cost
in sql server every query that you run
gets assigned
a cost and that means that
a cost of 5
means that it took 5 seconds
on this thing to run
now here's the funny part this code is
still in there
but there has been some small
increases in computing power since then
so a cost of five does not take five
seconds to run anymore
and it's even worse than that because if
i have
a intel cpu and you have another intel
cpu
well if your query is gonna cost five
and my query is going to cost
five we don't know if it's going to be
equally fast or slow
because we can't compare them
you can only compare to an identical
system and that means that you can only
compare
before and after tuning pretty much
right so back to
five seconds and a query cost of five
here is the dirty secrets the cost
threshold for parallelism i.e the cost
of a query
if you go above this number sql server
will look at that query and go
i'm pretty sure that i can throw you in
in parallel
and this means that 5 is an extremely
low number
and subsequently sql server thinks that
it could
throw any query in parallel and it
doesn't only think that it can
it will do it and this is where you end
up with spending more time
bringing back the skills than if i had
just
bit the bullet and encountered the
skills on my own
this is called parallelism skew
now we also have the max dop or the max
degrees of parallelism how many
cpus will we rope in for this specific
task
and the worst number you could have
is is running on all cpus because
i that's that's the the only way that i
can see that we can actually make
a parallel situation even worse that
would be if we run it on all the cpus
say for instance we have 24 cpus it's
going to take a lot longer
in most cases to gather the
skills from 24 people than if i had just
done it on one cpu or a smaller number
of cpus
so what is the default the default is
zero
which means yeah every cpu there is
sorry but it is what it is so we
actually have a pretty much
a perfect storm when it comes to really
really bad
default settings is this still the case
for sql server
2017 and 2019 well
2017 yes 2019 is actually going to go
i have an idea for you when you install
it it's going to give you a ballpark
figure
it's still not going to be ironclad but
it's going to be a
better ballpark figure
so how do you calculate this well up
until pretty recently there was no way
to
really calculate it um but there has
been some some advances with
um queries but i i use a pretty
simple rule of thumb because this works
for most cases
i'm going to set the max stop depending
on the number of cpus that i have
to one two or four for instance and
up until an up up
up until the number of eight i'm gonna
stay with the same
um i'm not gonna go higher than the
number of cpus that i have and
if i have eight cpus i'm probably gonna
be roughly around two
maybe four depending on my workload
if you are unfortunate enough to run
stuff like
oh i don't know sharepoint that requires
you to set the max drop of one i.e
it will never do anything in parallel
well i feel for you but
that's the case in in some uh sharepoint
it is the case
of some dynamics workloads as well
then i set the cost threshold for
parallelism to 50 and 50
is a good starting number because 5 is
way too
low and there is another rule of thumb
that says
maybe you want to parallelize 20 to 30
percent of your workload
so what i do is i set this to and then i
let stuff run for a bit
then i go back into the cache and see
how many of my plans are going in
parallel
and if it is more than 50 then i
increase this number
50 or if it's lower than 30
well then i decrease this number in
order to find
a reasonable number where i have
about 30 of my queries running in
parallel and again this
your your mileage may vary in you need
to know your workload
but this is the way you do it so the
good thing is
you can do these changes on your own
on your own in on the run you can do
this
on the fly you can do this with the
database running and you can also
from 2016 and upwards set this per
database because otherwise you're going
to be stuck in doing this on the server
level
however if you decide to change
mac stop or cost threshold for
parallelism
be aware that that you're you're going
to be
able to do it on the fly but it's going
to blow out your cash
it is going to have the same effect as
actually
restarting sql server just be aware of
it
because when you push the button you
might hear this
stream from the user somewhere and that
is never a comfortable thing
that's why i have my door closed and
pretty decent sound
protection
so in summary for this part
understand your workload as a dba and
i would argue as as a developer database
developer you need to
understand the workload and so many
people just focus on the code
the code works well sure it works but it
sucks
so you need to understand why is it
doing what it's doing
and why do you want it to do what it's
doing so it's all about the the
intersection between the users the
business and the actual code
you need to understand the consequences
of everything
before you do anything the the old adage
that when you pull the pin mr grenade is
no longer your friend
is very applicable because if you were
to set this number
on a running database you will blow out
the cache
and if you're looking at 192 gigs of
memory on that machine
that's going to be 166 gigs of
cash that it's just going to go the way
of the dodo not a good thing
and always always
test test everything and test it again
because at the end of the day it is your
posterior on the line
if something goes wrong
all right my friend called me up again
and this time he said what
what wait come on man how can code be
bad or good i mean if the code works
it must be good right really
does it let's look at that
so this is the way that humans
work well no not
in t sql well maybe some minds do but
now this is the way of
attacking a problem that's called role
by agonizing
row we tend to look at a data set from
the first row and then we go to the
second row then we go to the third row
and so on and so forth
this is r bar row by agonizing row
opposed to that is set theory
another example i'm going to go ahead
and guess that
most of you have done laundry i used to
ask people
or i used to say that everybody has done
laundry but it turns out that not
everybody has
anyways most of you have and there
are a couple of ways of doing this but
picture that you're
taking the laundry out of the the washer
and putting it
in for the dryer and then putting it
into uh
your cupboard your storage so if you
were to take a garment you fold the
garment
and you put it in the the cabinet and
then you take another garment you fold
the garment
and you put it in the cupboard that's
row
by agonizing row if i were to tell you
take this stuff out of the dryer and put
it into
the cupboard that's
set theory and that's imperative
sorry declarative instead of imperative
ways of looking at things and the
trouble is
the human mind is not very good at this
whole set
thing but this
is going to be dead slow we can do this
in another way and in secret server
it looks like this
from a database admin perspective this
is obvious and assumption is the mother
of all
you know what it's called and this is a
pretty
bad thing as a dba this is the way that
i expect people to behave because
i am not a developer but if you come to
this from
the either from a a normal
programming background or even worse if
you're using some kind of framework
then you might not neither know nor have
control over what the
the framework or the code that you're
creating is doing
but be aware that this is going to be
extremely
fast and the other one is going to be
pretty slow i'm going to give you
another example
so as you can very very clearly see here
we have two
examples of code this code does the same
thing
it was part of the the fill factor speed
freak competition many many years back
and the task was to produce a report by
month
listing the number of new subscribers
the number of subscribers who had left
ie churn
and a running total of current
subscribers the
the left example is using a row by row
approach with a temporary table and the
right one
is using a cte a common table expression
and some pretty clever set-based
trickery now
you can't see this and it's it's fine
you don't need to
crawl all the way up to the screen
because it is it's font size fly spec
that's not the point the point is there
are two ways of approaching this one is
the row by organizing row
one is the set-based way of doing things
so do you think there was any difference
in
speeds this is over
i think it was a hundred thousand rows
and
ten plus years ago so a hundred thousand
rows was
a bigger thing then than it is now but
the difference in speed is pretty
staggering
the set paste was one second the row by
agonizing row was 126 seconds
and this is the kind of performance
gains that you can see
if you stop explaining to sql server
how it should do things and simply just
tell it
what to do
keep that in mind we can keep going when
it comes to
creative coding
so here we have two select statements
they're they're doing the exact same
thing
but the problem is the human mind
really does not like
unordered lists i mean if i were to give
you a phone book
that had no sorting in it well it's
gonna be a while before you found my
phone number
yeah but as soon as we sort the thing
um in an alphabetical order well it's
easy to find my phone number that's the
whole idea of
of sorting and that's also the whole
idea of an index
now the trouble with sort is that it is
extremely
expensive from a computing standpoint
not only is it expensive it is also
what's known as a locking operator you
cannot
do a sort in parallel
so here we have an example the one
down here is no sort
the one over there is a sort
and there are a few really really really
bad things here
so remember the query cost i can't
say anything of a an absolute number
if your query costs 2 or 32
i don't know what that means i can only
say that your query costs
whatever number you set but if we were
to
compare the numbers like this
then it turns out that the first query
with the sword is kind of
uh i don't know eight times more
expensive no it's even worse than that
it's about 16 times more expensive
than not running a sort
already here we can see kind of a
pattern
but it gets worse funny that
because there's an exclamation mark and
that means in this case that
tempdb was used to to spill the data too
what does this mean well up until sql
server 20
the one of the first things that happen
when sql server is looking at a query is
that it estimates the
amount of memory it will need to fulfill
the query
and this is pretty much locked in stone
you cannot
under any circumstances change
this number for subsequent query runs or
for this query run
this is not true for 2017 and it's
definitely not true for 2019
but for the sake of the argument it you
can change it
so this means that sql server is going
to come up with a number
and then it's going to run the query
realize that holy crap it
had the completely wrong numbers going
in
the estimation was off the charts
so what does it do how can it get access
to more memory well
it's going to start eyeing tempdb and
tempdb is also known as the public
toilet of sql server because all
ends up there and that means that
you're going to see a lot of action on
temp tv which in turn is going to be
much much much slower
so spills is a really really bad
thing from a performance standpoint you
do not want to see this
2017 and 2019 is better at
re-evaluating a query
after the fact but it's it's it's not
foolproof at all
then we have a few ways of writing
functions and this is where most
developers go huh wait a second i know
functions
this is interesting and this is relevant
to my interests
well there are a few ways of writing
functions there there are three
kinds three main kinds of udfs or user
defined functions
we have the scalar function which gives
you exactly one result
you have a table valued or an inline
table valued function
which is going to give you a an object
that is a table
or you have a multi-statement table
valued function or an mstdf
a multi-statement table valued function
means that you have some
statements and you're going to return a
table the scalars are easy they're going
to return one
variable of a scalar type the other two
well let's look at that
so here we have a function get people by
state
and we are giving it a parameter
in this case it's going to be state and
we're going to return
people by state which is a virtual table
that contains first name and and last
name
inside of this function we're going to
put
stuff into this variable people buy
states we're going to select that from
the state
and so on and so forth but we also have
a
an if row count a kind of a
catch thingy to see if we have zero then
we're gonna put in no people found
this is a multi-statement table valued
function
so when we run this over there
we're going to see six to seven logical
reads and 125 milliseconds
of cpu time is that a lot well in this
case
it's unreasonably uh high i'm going to
show you why in a second
so the problem is
sql server does not have any statistics
on the number of rows that this query
will hit
because it cannot see inside of this
statement tdf
so it's going to go ahead and guess
and up until 2014 it's going to guess
that you will receive
exactly one row
and that is going to have some issues if
you're getting back oh i don't know 150
000 rows your your query plan is going
to
suck in the highest order
but it's okay because in in 2014 they
fixed it
because in 2014 it will expect to get
a hundred rows back
yeah but it's okay because in 2017 and
2019 they really fixed it
and they kind of did because 2019
is much much better at doing something
called
inlining or interleaving so it kind of
runs this query and peaks ahead and sees
oh we're going to get a lot of numbers
so
it can do a lot of trickery on the fly
so 2019 is much better handling this but
be aware that again it's still not
foolproof
what if we were to do something like
this instead we turn our multi-statement
tdf
into a single statement tvf it returns
the same thing the only thing that we
are not doing now
is the whole if statement so it becomes
a single statement
and thus sql server can see inside of it
and inline this as it's called and it
basically
rewrites this into a normal sql
statement that the engine can
handle and here we can use all the
the uh the statistics that we ever
needed and this one is going to be
blazingly fast because we're doing three
logical reads
and we don't even have a a number
cpu time is zero milliseconds and that
kind of is is better than 125.
so these are the weirder things that
you're
gonna hit as a developer because
functions are great everybody uses
functions but yes
they come with a bit of a cost if you
don't know exactly how the engine works
and speaking of queries and and how the
engine works there's something called
sargable or search argument able
and sargable means that sql server can
perform an
index seek using your search predicates
and this was said by brent ozar one of
the the
the really really heavy hitters in the
square server community
let's look at a few examples if i were
to do this
i'm going to select registration id date
left registrations
date left and from registrations where
the year
of datejoint is 1953. so i'm looking at
the year part of a date
and i'm throwing this query to sql
server
this cannot use an index because what
we're going to see is this we're going
to see an index scan
and scan means that we start at the top
and we go all the way to the bottom
an index scan or a table scan is
often not always but often a sign of a
bad
plan so here we have a 98
cost pretty much everything every
everything in the query that costed
anything was was due to this
and it's kind of a small picture but the
number of rows that we read was a
million
incidentally that's the number of rows
that we have in the table
but we only wanted 18 000
rows so the estimation is wrong
because we can't do an estimation
because we cannot use an index
so if we can't use an index we're forced
to just
go in and read all the rows if you're
coming from an oracle
background there's something called a
function based index
where you can actually index based on
the outcome of a function
so that would mean in that specific case
you could have run this
and had to hit an index now you can't
because the index which is on
let me go back to it's on datejoint and
datejoint is
a date i.e it contains both in the year
and the
the month and the day the index is on
that
it's not on only the year part so that's
why sql server cannot just
use the year part and look that up
for a human that's stupid that is
unbelievably stupid but that's the way
the engine works
um and there there's a lot of
interesting talks on the subject by for
instance joe
sack who is one of the the i think he's
one of the principal program managers
for
for sql server engineering and what he
does not know about the
the optimizer you don't want to know
so we keep going with this what if we
were to
move the function to the right side of
the
equality mark in this case we're going
to do select yada yada where datejoined
equals
convert and now we're just converting a
string to a date time so we have
something to compare with
and keep in mind that the index is on
datejoint
and now we are comparing apples to
apples and suddenly we have an index
seek
which means that we are like a torpedo
going straight to
the rows in the table and then we see
action number rows one expected number
rows
one voila much much faster
this is what we want to see
when it comes to dates
there's something called between be very
very very very
very wary with between this
is the right way to do a
comparison between two dates why
wouldn't i just use between
well between can be very inclusive
it can come back and haunt you with
dates that you were not expecting it to
have
this way i know exactly what it's going
to return
between can be or between is inclusive
so you might
actually get more dates on the ants that
you
expected and if there is one thing that
sql server people hates it surprises i
want to have my
database to be as boring as physically
possible i have another session that i
do it's called
boring is stable stable is good and yeah
so do this instead of using between
we can keep going with this because
this between it's going to do an index
seek
we are looking at 380 000 rows
which is still much better than a
million rows
so apparently we can do an index hit
despite doing a between that's kind of
useful
and then we have the whole use the tools
you're given one of the the
big things back in the 90s when i
started working with with computers were
that
you should create your database code to
be
agnostic it should be able to run on any
database
and that is beyond stupid in my view
because
we pay a lot of money to get access to
sql server or
oracle or db2 or whatever we're using
so why don't we learn the intricacies of
this specific implementation in order to
really really get stuff running fast
i mean this is a fully valid query
but we could do it like this as well
so just by knowing how the engine works
use the tools you're given use them read
up on it read the manual
i know it's not the male thing to do and
like a lot of other things that are not
considered male it's stupid
so read the manual and really figure out
how your code is going to impact
the query engine so
in summary for this part dehumanize your
code
there is no point in having your code
acting like
a human because it's probably going to
be a lot slower
learn the tool i.e read the manual and
always remember that nothing in life is
free everything you do
will have consequences when it comes to
performance
my friend was on the phone again and he
was positively furious with sql server
as it was mocking him even more than
usual
he swore that he had a query that
sometimes performed good
and sometimes performed impossibly bad
and he was sure that he had found a bug
in the date of his engine
he might have but let's look at a more
likely scenario first
here we have two queries and we're going
to be looking at
a number of rows from a table and we're
going to have
different customer ids because different
customers have a different number of
transactions
and if we just run these two queries
we're going to see that the top one was
a lot
of rows so sql server opted to do a
table scan which in this case were in
index and this is
which is going to give us a better
performance when it comes to
a huge number of rows
but the second one when we put in um the
the lower number
or the the other number for um
for um customer id 976
then it was a comparatively small number
of rows that we're gonna hit so that's
mean that means it's it's more efficient
to go into the index
find that address and then go into
the table and then keep keep jumping
that's that's called an index seek
but if we were to parameterize this
query
because that's going to give us two
completely different query plans
and it's going to go into the cache but
if we were to parameterize this query
and do it like this
so we're going to instead of
specifically stating or
explicitly stating the the um the number
we're going to
do a variable this means that we are
deferring
the query uh running we are we're only
going to cash this
we're not going to cash for number 125
or 976 or whatever it's it's going to be
cached in a more
general way the issue here is that sql
server does not know
what numbers we're going to be throwing
at it so again
we kind of took away a lot of the
information that the optimizer
uses to um to figure out how to best
attack a query
but the thing is the first time we run
this
that query will be cached
that query will be used for all
the subsequent runs of this
function so that means that the first
time we run this
and we show with number 401 this is
where parameter sniffing comes into play
it's going to sniff the parameter go
okay this
is the the um the query plan that i
think is the best choice for this
because we're going to give you back a
lot of data so we're going to lock this
in
as the best query plan
however what happens if we do this
remember that 976 gave us a whole
different
parameter a whole different career plan
previously
yeah that's going to be an issue because
we're going to be seeing this we're
looking at the
estimated number of rows it's going to
be 23 000 rows
but the actual number rows over there is
going to be 250.
so what is happening is we started
by showing the query engine 401
and 401 means that it's going to find a
lot of row so it's
opting for a table scan
but if we then show it
976 well
there is 976 so
this is parameter sniffing and this is a
serious
issue so how do you deal with this
well there are there are basically three
ways because
the engine cannot help you here it's
doing exactly what you asked it for
either you can go and add with recompile
on all your queries that is
effectively you're going to destroy all
the winnings of cashing it
in the first place so that
kind of sucks
or if you know your data you might be
able to use
optimize for and using optimize for
means that you're telling the optimizer
that
you might be expecting to see these
kinds of numbers
so it it guides the optimizer
somewhat or if you know exactly how your
data works
and you know exactly your your use cases
and you have a fairly static
set of numbers then you can do an if
then else
tree style thing and go for different
places to do
different query plans
that is a lot of work to keep up
and the the yeah the the upkeep is just
phenomenal for that one
but it is the fastest way of doing
things that that i can think of
my friend call me again
this is starting to become a bit of a
pattern and this time he had some
serious issues with blocking
because everything was blocking
everything else he said and this time
he wanted to check with me first before
he implemented his newest
brightest idea that he had gotten from
internet and that was putting no luck
on everything so
there there are two main locking
strategies that you can implement in
in a database it could either be a
pessimistic
or an optimistic locking scheme
sql server still defaults to a
pessimistic locking strategy
known as read committed where readers
blocked
writers by default so we have the read
uncommitted which means
that yeah we're not going to be
bothering with looking at if anything
is is committed before we read it as
soon as i read it i'm going to read
the the number but if it's not committed
i
i don't care we're going to have the
read committed which is the
the normal isolation lab that we are
running on in sql server
we have the repeatable read and
serializable and
as you keep going upwards in these it's
going to get slower and slower and
slower because you can only do one thing
at a time
in serializable so serializable is
basically having this huge database
database engine but you can only have
one person in the store at any given
time
and read uncommitted means that you can
have a whole darn
school bus in there and they can do
pretty much whatever they want
but you can't really trust what
they're they're seeing so we have
the other way of doing things the the
optimistic locking
this is where you have the read
committed snapshot and snapshot and this
means instead
that you are using tempdb to
cache a a row as you keep going
this is generally a good idea the read
committed snapshot
um because it's it's pretty much
transparent
to the user the snapshot means that you
need to change your code a bit so what
does this mean i'm going to give you an
example
um my parents they're old
and they decided that they wanted to go
on a trip with their their
other uh friends so they descended on
moss
on a um what's it called
um a travel agent that's the world i'm
looking for a travel agent
i don't know if there's gonna be any
more travel agents
still alive after the pandemic but
anyways so they they
walked through the door and like 20
people going we want to go to mallyarka
um or we're going to want to go to spain
or whatever and the
the the travel agent he went oh yes this
is going to be awesome
and that's what they they were starting
to talk about which flight they want to
do and how do they want to get there
he started to pre-book the seats for the
flights
he was locking the seats for the flights
after roughly 20 minutes they looked at
each other and go okay
now i don't think we're going to go to
spain maybe maybe maybe italy is better
uh we're going to be thinking about this
we'll come back after lunch and then
they left
and the travel agent was stuck with a
lot of pre-booked seats that he
didn't need so he released them and
that's what pessimistic locking is all
about
if there were another set of people that
wanted to go to spain
well they couldn't because there was no
seats left on the plane
but now there is
the issue so when they came back after
lunch
he was he had learned from his mistakes
so he did not touch
any of the the um the stuff until they
said yes okay we want to go to spain
on these dates on this flight that's
when he went in
to book the seats unfortunately
there were no seats and that's
optimistic locking
with
one thing that you could do is use
no lock to increase performance
and no lock means pretty much
read uncommitted so only use no lock if
you
a really know what you're doing
or b really hate your data because it's
going to
have some consequences it might be fast
but it's like an american car
it goes very very fast in a straight
line but do not try to turn because
you're going to end up in
a wall and it's the same thing with no
lock be extremely
careful with no luck
you might end up with stuff like dirty
reads this is the thing that
most people are aware of because you can
read data that has not been committed
and it could be rolled back sometime
after you've read it meaning you've read
data that
technically never existed you might see
missing rows or you might see
rows twice uh why not read multiple
versions of the same row which is
a risk due to how
the the way the an allocation scan works
or um if well a reader is
kind of sucky but if you were to put on
no lock on
insert update and deletes don't ever do
that because you might end up with index
corruption and that is a bad bad
bad thing so
keep in mind read committed snapshot
isolation or rcsi
which is generally a better way of doing
things because you're not
blocking in anywhere near the same way
as you do in just in normal read
committed you will have schema locks
i.e when you do a read you cannot change
the structure of the table kind of goes
without saying but
people still get surprised
there will be row versioning in tempdb
and what this means is that for every
row you're reading
there it will be a copy of it inside of
tempdb
so tempdb will be pulling double duty if
you will
to be a bit of an cash so this is the
way that you can
actually manipulate data and read the
old data
at the same time this means that you
will be putting
a lot more pressure on tempdb
and given the choice of a hard drive if
you have just
one ssd drive or solid state drive and
you can put whatever you want on on
on it from sql server most people are
going to go yeah i want to put indexes
on that
never do that always make sure that temp
db has the fastest
storage that you can find if you have an
nvme drive
or or a pci express or whatever make
sure that
tempdb is on the fastest drive
possible that's going to give you the
best performance
and if you're interested in in learning
more about these things
i can highly or i cannot recommend
this blog high enough kendra little
works out of red gate in in the uk these
days
she's done a ton of work she does a lot
of speaking on
locking blocking indexes programming in
general she is
super good at what she does and she's
written a lot of
the good stuff on the internet about
this
so in in summary for this one consider
optimistic locking
because it will probably give you better
performance due to not
blocking everything in sight keep in
mind the temp db
will be affected as in it's going to be
under a lot of pressure and be very very
wary of no luck as in
don't so in summary
do not fall for the idea that the
developer don't need any insight into
the database
and just a few small changes to your
database solution can
increase performance several times and
always
use the tools you're given
there are dbas and there are developers
some say they don't mix and there's um
there indeed plenty of examples where
they do not get along
i mean some people claim that that this
is the result of a fallout from a
especially vicious argument between the
dba and the developer
take my friend for example there's only
so much that you can do on your own
working together with invariably gets
you better results
and with dbas and developers working
side by side the tools available can be
used in the intended way
for maximum performance and profit
often new ideas spawned from the
collaboration itself
can result in basically a quantum leap
take this new knowledge and use it to
better your code
and better your relation with your dba
together we can do so much more and a
bright
future awaits thank you so much
my name is alexander and i thank you for
your time